a good pass and finish
by anthony davis and then boom
running the floor up three behind the
defense here james plays
behind the defense and then no ball
pressure temple
they're playing their smaller guys in
the back line
james just seals catches it in the
middle post
he backs in and hits a well defended
fatal
i love the decision by miami to double
davis and now
james in isolation and anthony davis
connects on that it puts really
incredible pressure on the defense
good defense there again from solomon
hill made it a tough shot but then they
turn it over james with the steal throws
it up
davis back up and this time able to
finish
james spins inside an easy path for the
basket but it's that sort of thing holly
gully you know
james gets inside goes reverse
left-handed 99.8
james goes inside and throws it down and
they've eased their way into a win as
james with another
transition opportunity get james ahead
of steam
and then the beautiful drop off to
dwight howard
he did not shoot the ball in game one
already three buckets
offensive rebound davis and follow the
size
so important for the lakers they out
rebounded miami by 18 in game one
with the left hand and then lebron james
[Applause]
powering his way to the rim lakers up
six early marks poster this is the best
player on the floor and we let him step
in rhythm a practice shot
nobody even chase him down and try to
contest it lebron james will knock that
shot down
and make some pay and it's like lebron
is saying i remember the last time you
defended me in the finals
i know your word attacks uses that upper
body strength
eliminates the contest takes the hit
gets the finish and going to the line
for the possible three-point
james gets on the back side of the zone
deuce and how about
anthony davis putting his stamp in
transition
season angle that's a weak attempt for
an offensive foul
10 assists lebron james knocks down the
three nice
james throws it up top to rondo
rondo inside to james falling away
jumpers good
31 for lebron james the lead is up to 13
as we're under three to play
to caruso great job of driving the seams
and dropping it off
to davis lebron james coming down the
lane with a full head of steam
gets the contact and the basket see
lebron james gets beat
by hero but what a what a great actor
james pass that's the 10th turnover
for the lakers 10 in the first quarter
we still have 243 remain
getting to a skirmish with morrison hero
right now
great job by lebron again he starts him
up
jay crowder with poor body position he
spins out
no ball pressure on rondo rondo whips a
pass to caldwell pope
james and the post catches and gets
hammered
count the basket and won but olynyk
with the
[Applause]
james finds some room fires a three
and knocks it down
davis guarded by iguodala olynyk looking
to help
makes him take a tough fall away shot
and it goes rondo
[Music]
and rondo pleading the case as we see
the
great put back by anthony he is such a
versatile big man and what a plus
for the heat to have him back caldwell
pope and anthony davis
quickly gets on the board that's good
offense good job by carl pope
james drives gets inside draws the foul
count it and one
lebron james sits down just a lot of
deflections too by the heat
rondo up top to morris morris goes at
olynyk pass inside
and anthony davis with rondo calling for
davis
[Applause]
nice feet inside good patience from
second block of the game for anthony
davis james a long three-pointer nails
it
that's his first three-point attempt and
it puts the lakers back up by one
he does a poor job of staying in front
of lebron he splits it
turns the corner puts his head down and
uses that upper body strength to attack
back-to-back plays they put the ball in
the hands of rondo you say why it's
because i can make sure
that i'm going to get a quality look
he's going to make the proper decision
the first time
again butler turns the corner
the ability to recover and look at this
this is excellent defense danny green
clears out
adebayo guards it that's just superior
skill right there
this guy big big time player
to pass and lebron keeping his team
three-point shooting of lebron james has
kept them in it
they have struggled in the half court
but in transition
davis the rebound throws it ahead to
james
james head down drives inside layup
count it and one
again defense leading to offense and the
lakers back within five lebron
james exploding here in the first half
with 21 points already go ahead
lebron james full steam ahead
this time a little pick and roll action
forces the help and then
finds anthony davis diving
james way downtown lebron james
crowder picks up james he tries another
three-pointer all night lebron j
points off the bench but into the hands
it goes to butler shot clock at four
three-pointer shot blocked davis his
third block of the game
james to danny green gets a good look
danny green with a big three-pointer
blocked shot james again surveying the
floor
he draws attention danny green turns the
corner attacks the paint
you need a hoop get the ball in the
hands of lebron james
and what a bad break for the heat
clearly got it off in time you saw that
yellow light at the top of the backboard
get our best player involved in as many
plays as possible lebron james good
defense there from davis
forces the turnover and james with the
flush down the other end
again when he has numbers the defense
isn't set
this is an amazing athlete they have
missed some very
makable point-blank shots as james
continues
to attack in transition but not as much
the last three games here of these
finals
you name them tim duncan charles barkley
carl malone
kevin mchale this is when lebron james
is
a nightmare to defend when he makes up
his mind that he's going to put
the ball down and attack the paint area
and he clipped uh
crowder on that drive the foul was on
crowder his first
and there's they were helping with
everybody now
that's half hearted help that's sticking
an arm in there
you got to stick your body in front of
lebron james if you want to win
many times we've seen this in the last
couple of months
his ability he's just too good in
transition with
gaps like that the power the athleticism
about to play the pass and lebron james
about to win another title
and with anthony davis arriving a
technical foul call on lebron james
if you can jump that high